it's been 10 years the jedi are all but
extinct
so there have been new tv spots for
obi-wan kenobi with new footage and
dialogue so let's break it down the
first tv spot begins with new dialogue
from obi-wan kenobi where he says it's
been 10 years the jedi are all but
extinct you can even hear the pain in
his voice indicating that the past
events that have taken place still not
healed for him he's still struggling
with what has happened and i'm sure
we'll see a lot of this in this show now
with the new footage we have a shot of
raver igniting her lightsaber in front
of uncle owen putting it close and
closer towards him as uncle owen closes
his eyes obviously very anxious and
stressed in this scene but he is
composing himself pretty well veiver can
obviously sense that uncle owen knows
something that she doesn't because as we
know uncle obviously knows about
kenobi's existence and that he is a
exiled jedi and now we don't know if
river is looking for kenobi or another
jedi whoever she is looking for she
knows that uncle and keeping something a
secret will keep kenobi a secret or will
he give up some information guess we'll
just have to wait and see we then have
new footage of obi-wan kenobi on daiyu
which is a new planet we'll see in this
tv show we see him walking through the
street for vohul and obviously keeping a
low profile and before we get to the
second tv spot we have one new shot of
the grand inquisitor here which is just
an extended scene of what we've seen
previously where he's spinning his
lightsaber then he tilts his head at the
end and i gotta say i actually really
like his mannerisms here because i know
like a lot of people i am very mixed on
the look of the grand inquisitor but if
the action and performance of the
character is really good then obviously
i can look past those floors so fingers
crossed for a really good grain
inquisitor here the next theory spot
opens with a ship flying towards this
planet now my prediction is that this
planet is a planet of dairy or planet
which recovered just previously this
might even be a shot of kenobi going
towards this planet which would make
sense as we do cut to a shot of obi-wan
kenobi walking through the streets of
daiyu again like we saw another tv spot
he is also keeping a low profile here he
has his hood over his head and is just
walking and keeping to himself then
later in the tv spot we have dialogue
from obi-wan where he is saying he is my
responsibility he must be trained thrown
to luke as he talks to uncle while this
dialogue takes place we have a quick new
shot of raver and uncle owen again much
like the previous tv spot raver is
sensing something about owen anyway
that's everything new with these tv
spots so if you did enjoy this breakdown
please like and subscribe and turn
notifications on to show your support
thanks for watching